which has existed since at least 2004
and possibly as early as 2001 so leaving
aside all the very troubling kind of
racist overtones of the macro as well as
the issue of whether it's funny or not
it's extremely popular and you're going
to get raped is now this bike catch
phrase that's used in competitive in
argumentative context it shows up in a
lot of places so whether you like it or
not this is like this is the major
reference or the Edward back room so
this macro these loved tenderly macro it
functions just like that you've got to
get raped macro and it doesn't function
without that reference right so you're
going to get raped plays on viewers
perceptions of black and possibly
homeless guys the subject of it is
widely assumed to be homeless when you
see people talking about macro and then
love tenderly puts these assumptions in
conversation with perceptions of edward
cullen and robert pattinson right so
most members have taunt like when they
were asked about it agreed that Edward
is abusive and Robert Pattinson his
homeless-looking or absolved in their
words right like because your little go
to like sex calls would be sort of
unkempt and these are like common
complaints this is not just on Twilight
right everybody just likes twilight
esteem says these things about edward
and robert pattinson but the normal
narrative that's being put out in the
crest and that people assume that
Twilight fans are into is the Edward is
the perfect boyfriend and robert
pattinson is the heart prob so the
cognitive dissonance is what's fine and
what you need to remember what this is
that Twilight Twilight members are
behaving in many ways like fans right
there they're following obsessively
everything that happens there i use that
term they're following everything that
happens in the twilight books they're
following actors lives of cetera they
just have a very different perspective
on what is going
so the distance between the way that
Edward is being portrayed here in the
way that means being portrayed sort of
in the media is what gives the macro
kind of an analytic punch so by aligning
these two things whoever he's working
this macro is forced to think about
Edwards actions in any light he isn't a
literal racist in the books right he's
just sort of creepy but by lighting the
idea of rape with being robbed tenderly
the macro actually does make an argument
it's a book his deductions are creepy
and scary and everybody's right thing is
that you know creepy guy that your
series going to rape you not romantic
and sexy like the normal narrative goes
the other thing about this is that the
gayest functions really interestingly
right so Edward is like blooming and
assertive like goofy and sort of
medicine in this picture but in the
context of the macro the viewer is given
the power to say no right you're looking
back and you're like cut Edward you
douche right so the experience of
reading a macro isn't complete until the
viewer reacts i dealing with humor right
drowning him as a mainstream
understanding Twilight out with laughter
and making a little bit of a stretch to
to bring the glasses with medusa into
this but i think that it's really valid
because the point of this macro and many
many others like it is that they're
challenging this this expected gender
role story of twilight with with their
laughter
so I'm going to really quickly sort of
skim over the next part of my thesis in
which I'm comparing these macros which
have totally been not not dealt with in
literature in the the literature in
general with sandals which of the
doublet somewhat extensively and this is
actually a slide that is changing yeah
so right Santa's and macros behave very
similarly in some ways they're both
created in communities of interpretation
and criticism communities develop
methods of reading their difficult for
outsiders to comprehend right so if you
see a salmon you can understand that
before you don't know what it's doing
they can both service as a way to mess
with expectations about the male gaze
there's a lot of scholarship about that
the D and recontextualization of
narrative our key components of their
some macros that take like an entire
scene and recontextualize it with new
captions this last point actually has
changed now I am working into my thesis
that there are many there are many
Sandman's that are intended to be
humorous but they don't typically is
dealt with in the academic corpus they
haven't been talked about very much and
i think that there's a lot of reasons
for that I think there's a lot of
reasons why things like macros sanded or
if we look more broadly things like
silks write songs that are like sort of
parody that sort of just refined that
fans will sang that are based in in the
original the original story world
there's a lot of reasons why these
things don't get talked about in the fan
studies corpus very much and I think
that one of the reasons is the humor
element right it's just plain difficult
to talk about humor you know as you guys
probably noticed with me talking about
the Edward macro it's always either like
too serious or to unserious for academic
discourse but there's not a part of this
which is that the fan cultures that we
usually study are
female fan cultures and to quote Nancy
Walker humor is at odds with a
conventional definition of ideal
womanhood he worries aggressive women
are passive the humorist occupies a
position of superiority women are
inferior so now I want to illustrate
this for you that's why I made this
argument right that were uncomfortable
with the idea of funny women and this is
part of why we ignore humorous
productions by Lynn to illustrate this
the first American collection of women
Sumer was published in eighteen eighty
five I thought that most of you didn't
know that before 80 85 there were I seen
a Lyris that existed ever out of the
Navy Jane Austen um there were no
collections of women see were in English
that i know of or that nancy walker news
/ than anybody i've read Bob knows up
until nineteen seventy six and it was
called titters and titters was subtitled
the first collection of humor by women
because the wit of women was so scared
furthermore as late as the early
nineties and possibly to this day when
we did not appear in any major
collections of significant American
humor despite that they're really
prominent that you were seeing I mean
like Dorothy Parker just using lists so
many people from even just this century
and yet they're not showing up in
academic discussions of American humor
so I think that there's a good strong
argument for the fact that they've
fallen out the academic discourse and so
you know how do you start talking about
funny female fans like where do you
begin with that but there's another
reason that we might exclude humor from
our discussion of fans and that's the
consumer potentially complicates our
understanding of what a fan is
so in our fan cultures map Hills who is
one of the major scholars is ready that
was right now refuses to give a
definition of San but he privileges
people who claim the fan identity who
assumes that the natural object of San
studies is self-identified fans Cornell
San boss we can even see quoted above so
that sanam is the regular emotionally
involved consumption in a given popular
text or narrative and he describes the
repeated consumption of any text as
affection and affection for the text so
well this seems to potentially include
emotional investments that aren't
totally positive the rest of fans
doesn't explore the possibility of
frustrations and animosities towards
given text to write the only looks at
people who are like yeah I love it I
here where you can see national kind of
problem a tightness because even the
most good-natured humor is poking
chronic something even the most
good-natured Kimura is potentially you
know say yeah I'm not totally ungrateful
of this how can you make a joke where
there's no butt of the joke I guess it's
possible but it's very hard um and this
especially is problematized by things
like the macros that Twilight is
producing which are also kind of biting
commentary generally speaking or funny
sandins right Santa's are traditionally
understood as as critique but when
they're funny it's like an extra level
like they're getting this joy and
critique um and that's hard to deal with
how can you enjoy making fun of
something so much and still be a fan is
that even possible and yet the people
that I looked at in my ass a graphic
study of Twilight behave exactly like
fans do they observe everything that
goes on
Twilight they discuss the themes of it
they look at the actors they follow
everything they do I found out more from
them about like what was happening in
the world of Twilight than I did from
the Twilight but purely fan sites that I
found so I talked in my previous these
presentations about Jonathan Gray's
ideas about fans which are
representative of he he claims that you
have a nucleus which is the fan or the
clothes reader and then you've got the
non fan in the anti sandwich are like
the electron this makes this nice little
diagram of the atomic conception of
Sandin and their step forward right
you've now got a fan is done FFN someone
who hates something and they're in
conversation with each other from but
they're really too simplistic and
they're being taken up in wider invited
conversation a lot of people that I
interviewed without any prompting
identify themselves as oh I'm a fan or
oh I'm anti-fan and this as I hope you
can see even if it is a step beyond like
hills or San boss saying that um you
know fans are our self-identified fans
who love the text um it'll ideas left
wat light so it erases really complex
effective engagement with text and makes
it harder for us to study critical
practices like cracking serious jokes um
I had considered suggesting a term that
[ __ ] light came up with which was wall
fan of Edmond a man who loves to make
fun of something to the wolves but i
think that would only mess this up even
more right we're not going to get
through this by creating more categories
rather I think we really need to rethink
our concept of what we're studying when
we're studying fans and kind people who
are receiving attack
so my conclusions are that the term span
and the conception of my field as San
studies is deeply flawed for a variety
of reasons that Jonathan grades work to
challenge this was a step in the right
direction but he doesn't go far enough
in order to break down these artificial
terms and instead be looking at the
relationship of the reader to the text
that this is reflective of cultural
biases against women's humor in
particular and it also causes us to miss
important cultural phenomena like macros
and like other fancy reproductions he
was connections in general really it's
not inherent to the way this field was
constructed its origins Henry for
instance talks about he talks about
silks he talks about plan humor Vietnam
initially did not even talk about fans
and her some of the work she didn't use
the term if said she was focused on
readers who had something to say about
Dallas in her case and easily ready by
gamma rays to all effectively engaged
critical and interpretive communities
that are based around popular text and
all their productions so changing with
focus from this idea of here is a thing
called a fan to here is a relationship
that some people have with the text we
want to say the relationship and not
necessarily the person
so questions
just start off so um the term past
nineties is thinking quad yeah what
would you propose instruments of bitters
I don't know and this is a master system
let me do a sense of how that that how
we can circumvent behind us well I think
additional constraints so I didn't pay
for this I've never keep it is it's and
sizes a term that's not actually like
there's no program in Sam studies that
exists but I know if it's not cemented
yet and I think reliably arguing against
is cementing it as a field per se I
think that I arguing that it should be
viewed all right I mean you criticize
the UNAM for sort of talking about this
is audience studies which I did not get
fed no sorry what was her what was your
comment about was that she did a good
thing by talking about it audience that
was an answer I don't know if that's the
answer he said you like that something
that has I guess I really don't know yes
miss things potentially good but I
haven't I haven't I guess I just don't
feel like I in a position to say the key
thing for me is that really the key
point for me has has been that Sam
studies is giving up sliders I was
wondering that audience days is I feel
like it fit suggest we're looking at
like the nonsense that Johnson great
encouraging and I think that that cannot
be Kate's any motion for advanced
studies are interested in that are
interested then on
and that may be audience I used to dress
that there's a broader I don't know I
I'm that way I don't know the answers
that question I wouldn't follow up on
that I sympathize with the idea that if
we focus too much on and as a category
of person that you can pull in a lot of
directions and make it hard to see
something and so I think idea that to
get through this or go to some next
stage very smart very interesting you
know it's a question of sorrow it seems
to me so the answer to one of ways to
think about the answer Williams question
is you know is what are you trying to
get to my dears a gap through this and
gas certainly don't okay well what are
we trying to get through and poor I hear
a few things coming out there that means
very provocative you know one is a humor
you know it's very hard to deal with I'm
not sure they did know fans do with
humor I guess I was thinking of the
football fans who put the bag over their
head right hello and and I know yeah I
know yeah lots of distinction yeah and
that's all fine but I guess you know
still like you know it seems means where
where you want to go away I just think
it's interesting to say well it's about
why it distracts us this term fan is it
makes it as an old fan somehow share the
same emotional attachment and so the old
know so then there's just categories
Japan and you're getting a certain kind
of
you want to say that there's this more
complicated relationship but I think
this is always parked their fans love
and hate you know I do think that's yeah
part of being a fan in any situation
maybe but the humor ma I think it's true
humor is especially hard to talk about i
mean it's like I think there's something
about academic discourse here that we we
don't be so serious right where all our
clothes and you know these rules about
what you can and cannot do dreamers
we'll get to that later but is it so so
I guess I guess asking that my question
that is you know I'm gonna agree with
with you so far but then the question so
what would you want to do with it like
where do you want to take this to say
okay now this is I can't get to where I
want to get to so that's I'm still
haven't heard where you want to get it
right so so why are things about this is
that my family's isn't seriously
developed over to work right at first I
was just in the second graphic study and
there's even like serious developments
in my concept of the thesis like
yesterday after it already made my
thesis presentation so fortunately
nothing that's good work it but um but I
think that for me it the thing that I am
really most deeply interested in that
maybe I didn't fully express who this is
it's a concern for the calcification of
life which particular groups of bands
that we are going to study so right
there's there's this whole thing where
we studied the one who write fanfiction
you know we study people who are in this
tradition of media sense and then you
are not folks payroll fans which is a
people will use for those who did not
sort of come up through the the Star
Trek so whatever you know and also you
know for studying male fans we've
studies certain behaviors of theirs and
force any female fancy study other bit
behaviors that are theirs so when he
bring out humor with football fans the
others a lot of stuff about men doing
Perry and some of that most of that is
not actually in conversation with people
who had call themself Stan studies
scholars and there's you know so it's
just I feel like there's all these
calcifications that are existing and I
would really like to or that are
beginning to come to be and I would
really like to sort of smash those down
and as other thing that I think that
maybe the idea of audience site is where
I want to go with this the idea that
their audiences that are here not yet
with jumping rate is talking about them
as it happened in very sacked once but
rather as as a more cited thing right as
a
an individual thing for you
I
I
but we come
more commercial because I know that
you're interested you are a most
institutions of the court are or as well
as market yeah so I would think about
this a lot actually Oh as i know that
you also know and one of the things i
think that people's perceptions of what
a fan is who are in the sort of
forbidden and energy in the world are
very unmixed right they're very much
focused on me as your exams are giving
an adulation and completely love
everything they do and i think that in
recent years that's been challenged to
some degree and people don't necessarily
understand that even though they may be
are not purely logical reasonable that's
not necessarily the end of the world
right that you can you can look at
reactions and be like okay here here are
these reactions to my work somewhere
good sound / bad how can i play too
these but i'm looking forward to
exploring that a little more thinking
harder about very controversial things
like pledged by light right where man
all the people of arms wat i went to see
the twilight movies and make fun of them
in theaters and man they were they were
putting some more money in the pockets
of of the people who were were putting
on friday so i think it's an interesting
way to go for marketing and poor
commercial allegations but rough lines
are drawn my own one and you can wear a
bra vector of Douglas suggests that
humor emerges when we are potentially
contradictory ideas yeah same yeah and
humorous the way you negotiate through
those contradictions absolutely you know
so it's not think about the male fans
for a moment historically there has been
a discourse with a band of not written
in academia about male fans using humor
negotiate the knowledge base of the text
and to signal their emotional distance
room yep as a way to negotiating what it
means van a male at the same time so the
question and then traditionally that's
opposed to the more immediately engaged
female fans room romance or melodrama
have been the dominant so I'm wondering
how that gets complicated by this
reading are we are you know Pam simply
adopting the male posture is its
contradiction inscribed or is there the
intensity or ambivalence about closeness
and distance
or critical engagement and emotional
investment that's very different from
what's been characterized so I think
that it depends on which group you're
talking about i think that for the
twilight group i would say yes it is the
same impulse um because because of the
fact is the test is so highly gendered
and pilot never represented as so female
it's so incredibly like irrational and
you know every every possible turn that
you can use for that I think there
really is something happening with the
twilight fan group where they are both
gone to test and absolutely have to
somehow to go she ate it I'm not a girl
like that however the fans any community
which I'm also looking at i think is is
different it's always right it's equally
the human standards are easily
overlooked but many of them do speak to
a closeness to the text that that
doesn't come up as much in my life that
is more more days so i think that is a
really great insight and i think that
both are true for different communities
and i think this just points back to why
you can't say like ended here are all
fans right like why I can't just propose
the category of Lal fans who like to
make front of the text and like leave it
there which would be very neat and let
me tell you how much I would love to do
that but but I can't do that because
different communities of fans are using
humor is interacting with the taxi
any
generally speaking I would say that the
media has has gotten night search of
fans in the heisman in segments and I
think that is true so I guess I'm
optimistic but but then their coverage
of Twilight fans has been were light has
been throat which is part of what
interests me in it right because it
seemed like base means we're getting
treated more and more reasonably from
even just from the time that I I started
becoming involved in Harry Potter fan
and so now they're treated much more
sympathetically but Twilight fans are
this real case where they're like back
to all of the things that are you know
back to describing all the scary things
about them back to the metal maniacs
back to you know all the stereotypes so
I don't know what to say on that topic I
think it probably is a little bit and
there's not really the same social panic
but I think existed around the beetle
maniac so that's good because we use is
I I have a lot at the worst time I under
questioning about
corporeality corporeality yeah so a lot
of ladies of the old meanie answers yes
Reverend and a lot of just talked about
how women really these sort of these
media to the head of effective
relationship would is about yeah like
this so like this is different yeah a
lot of one ways quad like is that these
people are in a fiscal space screaming
at an actual person all right yes it's
there it's not good la time this woman
so that what I'm curious about is if you
have thoughts about this or interface
between on the one hand this sort of
intellectualized humor let me talk about
all of the all of the references that
have to government macros great in
contrast haha this kind of fan behavior
which is not online and can it be done
in a bowl yes it can in fact [ __ ] light
has done many things where they actually
showed up to things that they knew that
they were going to be is a lot like
right when anonymous comes and like you
know live troll somebody they like what
they'll do things like they'll organize
like a Twilight prom which is going to
happen this is something that has
actually legitimately happened like
Stephenie Meyer did throw a twilight
prom it was for serious business so
they'll show up like a bookstore or
whatever and have like their toilet from
they're all like cosplay but it really
ridiculous over-the-top ways and
sometimes they do the thing were they
some power and body a macro or whatever
so so they'll show up in person and they
actually do have a lot of physical
meeting I was surprised when I started
looking at the community I just didn't
have time to talk about how this but a
lot of them talk on the phone text
message I actually interviewed some
people in person who live in Boston and
they were totally cool with that it was
it was a really interesting thing
because i think that people assume that
like this is going to be totally
disembodied but in reality the two items
were meeting up and were were engaging
face-to-face so I think there is an
important question in that embodiment
and like the way that that people have
talked about being right one other thing
though is that I use this because it's
nice to illustrate and it's hard to like
just show a picture of the website be
like hey guys but these fans are
probably also involved in online movies
right so so it shouldn't be you should
be even though even though the language
of evaluative used to talk about fri
like man we should assume that that
means that like the laughing fans are
online and the serious fans are all why
isn't nothing of them being a whether
they're two different routes on boat and
the expression we did one of them would
work differently all that offline right
on line one seems very intellectual and
referential and they're sort of you know
that you has a humor is there is
reliable
yeah that might map out whether they're
in physical space or not it doesn't
hardly seem to I mean it seems like
mostly they're they're translating the
intellectual humor and at the rate of
eight this will analog so out of
curiosity here is the set of heuristic
distinctions and I know they're all
bound together but i'm curious about
brain or emphasises with so there's the
community aspect which embody yeah
corporal you're looking at it that's
we're doing our thing graphic research
there's an identity rescue where is a
highly effective mode you've got to
really understand how people think
consider ourselves and there's maybe the
issue of engagement the activities that
manifestations the things that people
right all right and they're all bound
together but I can have the same like
where you're very interest really is
because this might offend solve the
problem of reification of a social group
has fans are the actual so this is
really change of the course of the
thesis and I think that's why there's
some amount of white confusion as to
what my focus is because until very
recently I was confused as to what I
focus life but but it really is about so
so in in the thesis itself my focus is
definitely on the productions of the
community and
for a number of things like those macros
and then i'm using the rest as as see
exciting as sort of showing you like
there's a lot more that we could do with
this but but here are the macarons and
the reason I'm doing that is because
that has been a traditional thing that
people example you'll be doing right
like they will be a tactic and then
we're going to do some kind of a focus
on this fan but you know they're looking
at a bit and they're going close to be
hit with it I don't know if that
actually answered your question but
the self regulation we seem to prepare
I was really interesting material
they should keep
ah
but thinking about are there any wires
or because you
is whether an outlier data points yea i
meant also like maybe not because itself
in group but then courtesan deviant
how's it regularly it's like you stepped
into girl world it really is so this is
something that i had i really do not
have time to talk about this in the
thesis otherwise i would go away it's
this stuff right so as there's all this
really cool stuff is actually happening
with the relationships between people
and so on but but instead because i have
only like 100 pages to write this in
I've been focusing sort of on that the
things that they leave behind as they go
through it but in my in my study man
they will drawn people out of the group
and in fact they say well there's like
this whole language around what happens
when somebody is starting to get too
serious business or when somebody has
gone too far and ended everybody right
like there's these two ways that you can
get drummed out of the ditch wat light
group and they'll talk about how you can
like you you posted when is the term not
flail you post a flounce coast right so
like when you've been drummed out of the
group because everybody loads you either
because you're too serious business or
because of 22 major fun things
traditionally people will post a flounce
post about like oh I really hate trot
light right and from their respected
they're like dude trot light is horrible
people who have just kicked me out by
like making my life miserable a better
because while I find this really funny
and no I say front of the flaps open
by basically being really need to them
and sending legs like by posting macros
that are I'm you know right guys are so
mean macros in contexts where they're
going to be insulting and by posting
animated gifs which I also didn't get a
chance to talk about but there's like
blossom and ingest that they used to
express emotions and hosting those like
ones that people I rolling on all your
posts and so on so it really it's like
stepping into a little bit uh-huh but
yeah very very strongly regulated
community internally would be an entire
world are there any men did one of the
enrollment ago geez yeah I so in my time
orange wat light I captured for that and
choose them are boyfriends of people who
were there and two of the per game and
the gay guys generally behaved like
anything like general tonic like this
but but when I interview them they're
like yeah I totally out girl the girls
and the guys were all they were just
like I really like and it's funny
they're hilarious like these women are
really funny and I like being here and
my girlfriend's on here and she's really
into it and so like it's fun for me to
watch what's going on and it gives you
an insight into the minds of women which
I thought was sort of scary but but so
there were a very few everybody in
twilight was very excited to have him
there it was like no you should go talk
to the guy he can give you this
perspective you know but yeah internal
polling was like
ninety-nine percent women I have no
reason to doubt that I mean I am sure
it's not scientific sample but I have no
reasons doubt that that the polls were
not reflective of what the people who
are posting the most soon someone
because we should probably wrap up